getting dressed up is so much fun
i am so lucky that i have this
amazing job and i get to wear clothes
and get in touch with my feminine side
because normally i'm in sweatpants with
no makeup
and we've all been stuck at home and
casual
loungewear has just become the norm it's
like
we've kind of let go i don't want to say
given up because that sounds depressing
but
our new norm has created a certain
you know attire that is not the most
fancy and put together and
not only is it taking a toll on our
closets it's taking a toll
on our relationships too for so many
couples
gone are the days of getting dressed up
for each other and keeping that spark
alive
miriam and seidel have been married for
14 years and are looking for a little
romance refresh and they join us now
hi guys
[Applause]
look at you holding hands in your pod
yeah he's so beautiful
it's so beautiful miriam
now you reached out and told us that you
were kind of
looking for a little helping hand a
little
you know love like what's going on well
you know we're stuck in this pandemic
we wear the same thing all the time i'm
a mom
he's a dad we get busy with school stuff
we're almost married for like 18 years
no we've been married 14. oh i'm sorry
just
too crazy see so
we don't we don't have time to even
remember anything and you know and the
romance
well we're stuck home with the kids and
i want to feel sexy again
okay well i just want to ignite that
spark for you guys
again and boy listen
we have the couple to do it they are the
cutest duo
on ig they are super famous they
continue to nail it when it comes to
boosting romance through their wardrobe
and artistry please welcome back to the
show
the young emperors nelson tibergian
and isabel shapoon
thank you i love you guys isabel and
nelson
are i mean you're just my icons our
heroes you bring so much
joy and isabel question
what you know power can fashion
bring to a relationship well i think the
power of fashion is huge i think fashion
is not only
part of our culture as humans or history
but it's also an emotional thing it's
not just
function it's an emotional thing and i
think when you dress
in a way that makes you confident you
shine and you glow
and you become attractive to the world
because you are yourself attractive to
yourself
and i think that's super important in a
relationship to maintain that and to
not lose yourself i agree and
i mean when you dress up you present
differently
and it's as much for you as it is for
someone else okay let's do this
nelson i would like you to take cedel
and
isabel i would like you to take miriam
and both of you can work your magic
i just love you guys so much it hurts oh
my god
we love you so much we're excited first
of all check it out
thank you yes
all right let's go i started this show
with isabella nelson i'm so happy we're
here again together
all right fun and mystery and we're
going to keep you
all a part of it until the end of the
show when we reveal these brand new
looks
and we're going to check in with nelson
and isabel
cedall and miriam let's take a peek at
nelson and seydell
oh and isabelle and miriam
oh fantastic oh i see some shoe action
all right that always speaks to us girls
what is it with us in shoes
all right well i can't wait to see both
of them
at the end of our show let's see what uh
miriam and seidel look like before
who doesn't love a before and after cute
all right
okay say dal come on out
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
i feel great i feel comfortable
most importantly i hope this makes my
wife feel good
and happy wife you know makes everything
not just on the outside look at this
so good i think you look so handsome
thank you and nelson thank you
so happy the smile
and the pack say it all okay we had you
and miriam in separate green rooms
backstage are you excited to see her
can't wait okay we haven't seen her
either all right come on out miriam
[Applause]
oh my god
choose mine right right i mean
wow oh now you have makeup
love it love it love it thank you drew
thank you so much thank you
i feel great i feel like a million bucks
wait till tonight
well thank you miriam and stay down
that's exactly what i was hoping for
and the young emperors isabelle and
nelson
jatem jetemchi
thank you so much everybody for watching
get a little dressed up
surprise someone you know why not
have a wonderful day